[Musique]
quiconque est agriculteur le sait la
besoins une requiertant passion et
patience et dans le calendrier Ryu
beaucoup de patience car pour accéder à
sa terre il doit traverser la route 132
plusieurs fois par jour il faut quand
même attendre que les deux côtés soient
libres et ça traverse pas instantanément
la batteuse ça va lentement et on peut
pas aller plus vite vous allez montrer
ça
il dit de voir patienter des fois
jusqu'à 15 minutes avant de pouvoir
s'élancer c'est qu'au grand dames
d'André Rieu la 132 ici fait office
d'autoroute parce que l'autoroute 20
s'arrête avant Trois Pistoles pour ne
reprendre karimouski l'anomalie fait en
sorte que la route 132 et la seule voie
pour se rendre en Gaspésie
50 km de discorde qui ont souvent fait
l'objet de tractations politiques la
route 20 vous savez à s'est arrêtée à
Rivière-du-Loup a donné le feu vert à la
finalisation de l'autoroute
compléter donc l'autoroute de kakouna
jusqu'au Bic juste avant la ville de
trois-pistol il y a un fameux pont à
construire l'histoire du prolongement de
l'autoroute 20 est une saga truffée de
détour depuis plus de 40 ans cette année
le gouvernement de la carte le réins
inscrit dans le Plan québécois des
infrastructures mais une vie vous
position s'organise contre le projet il
y a 40 ans peut-être que construire des
routes c'est ce qu'on faisait de mieux
peut-être mais pas en 2022 Sébastien
Riou est membre d'un groupe citoyen
opposé au parachèvement de l'autoroute
qui inclut la construction d'un pont
au-dessus de la rivière Trois Pistoles
c'est la santé des gens qui est en jeu
c'est la protection de notre
environnement
le GIEC ne cesse de le rappeler
l'urgence climatique construire une
route c'est des reste de plus à la
construction au déplacement son groupe
propose un bouquet de solutions pour
contrer les problèmes de sécurité et de
fluidité développement du transport
collectif interrégional bonification du
transport ferroviaire et nous réfection
de la route 132 incluant l'ajout de
voies de contournement bien sûr que
réfléchir un peu innover ça demande un
peu plus de force nous c'est ce qu'on
dit ce qu'on sait ce qu'on doit faire en
2022 se forcer un petit peu plus si la
majorité de la population et des élus
est favorable aux travaux en raison
surtout du fort à chalandage et du
nombre élevé d'accidents sur ce tronçon
de route presque un tous les trois jours
en moyenne au cours des cinq dernières
années un élucieux pose toutefois le
nouveau maire de Trois Pistoles on parle
de 27 hectares de taille humide de zones
6.7 hectares des rabelières qui sera
touchée on parle aussi de 216 hectares
de terre cultivées on parle de terre en
culture les lieux de enfin crois aussi
qu'il faut à tout prix protéger la
rivière Trois Pistoles en fait que le
second là affecte grandement la qualité
de la rivière ce qui l'inquiète surtout
c'est le manque de transparence du
ministère des Transports il y a une
citoyenne justement en début de l'été
qui a demandé les études géotechniques
il est arrivé le document m'a 90 % qui
avait puis le MTQ par la suite nous dit
ben là on est content des informations
qu'on a puis on a on a juste pas besoin
de le diffuser Philippe Gilbert dit
qu'il ne peut pas non plus ignorer les
impacts économiques pour sa ville car
selon lui plusieurs municipalités ont
souffert d'être contournées par
l'autoroute comme à l'île Verte certains
commerces ont même dû mettre la clé sous
la porte on veut des réponses là le MTQ
nous dit que le projet prolongement de
l'autoroute 20 c'est la meilleure
solution mais on n'a pas d'autres
solutions qui ont été proposées pour
André Riou la solution est évidente s'il
dit se soucier lui aussi l'environnement
il croit que la sécurité et la qualité
de vie des résidents qu'on passe enfin à
l'action si on n'avait pas dépensé
autant d'argent à faire des
améliorations des 50 60 dernières années
on aurait déjà une autoroute qui on
aurait pu on en parlerait pas
l'environnement même s'il reste encore
bien des étapes à franchir pour que le
projet se concrétise dont des études et
des consultations sur le plan politique
toutes les conditions semblent enfin
réunies une inconnue de taille demeure
celle de l'acceptabilité sociale
difficile à ignorer en 2022 ici Elisa
serrer Radio-Canada Trois Pistoles